un corps parfait du moins on l'espère ce
soir à l'olympia pour la rentrée de
véronique sanson reportage de jean
jacques dufour samson ce n'est
évidemment pas ulysse mais après un long
voyage au state
elle est revenue vivre le reste de son
âge à la maison c'est à dire aux
environs de paris sur les bords de la
seine à propos de seine elle est à
partir de ce soir sur celle de l'olympia
toujours autant de charme qu'il ya 15
ans lors de ses débuts
et puis toujours cette voix qui est
selon elle une sorte de cadeau divin
c'est vrai c'est vrai je sais que c'est
un peu vous êtes dire ça mais moi
j'avais une une idole c'était john
warwick et toutes les filles et tous les
gens qui vibrait avec leur voiture qui
avait un vibrato me fascinait parce que
moi je savais pas du tout le faire et je
crois que j'ai tellement voulu bien jour
j'étais chez mes parents
selon me soutient
cette jeune fille qui joue du piano à 6
comme fats domino ne connais rien aux
seuls faits
une révélation qui m'a interloqué
incroyable non c'est très bien conduire
une voiture sans avoir votre permis je
pense qu'à une chose et ça me gêne pas
du tout
on a une première partie où on s'est
pressée très calme c'est qu'on peut
c'est tout en noir et blanc comme un
film en noir et blanc et c'est trés
intimiste alors que la deuxième partie
la véhicules américains pourquoi les
nôtres sont pas bons kouassi s'ils sont
très bons mais moi c'est mes copains de
là bas et comme j'avais vraiment envie
de rejouer avec eux donc je les ai
appelés et vous vraiment une énergie
complètement formidable coup nettement
positive ils sont extraordinaires